banderoles et pancartes brandies dans le
19e arrondissement de paris place
stalingrad
pour protester contre la crise du crack
qui perdure ces riverains s'opposent à
l'ouverture de salles dédiées à la
consommation de crack dans des zones
habitées et à la mauvaise prise en
charge des toxicomanes qui perdure
depuis des années en fait on on estime
qu'en tant riverains dans tout paris on
a droit à la sécurité à la sérénité on a
le droit d'élever nos enfants dans la
tranquillité donc je pense que la patate
chaude que tout le monde se refile ça
suffit il est temps de faire un plan non
pas locales et régionales on veut un
plan national on est là parce que
justement on veut montrer qu'on n'est
pas du tout d'accord si vous voulez nous
nous sommes pour l'instant la seule
salle de shoot qui a été créée il ya
maintenant cinq ans et on se mobilise
depuis cinq ans pour que cette salle de
shoot ne soit plus dans une zone habitée
avec des gens de tous âges et surtout
des enfants aussi donc on voudrait que
si il devait y avoir salles de
consommation qu'elle ne soit pas dans
une zone habitée depuis des mois les
consommateurs de crack sont sans cesse
déplacer d'un endroit à l'autre de la
capitale d'abord la colline du crack
puis le quartier de stalingrad et les
jardins d'eole depuis le 24 septembre
ils sont désormais installés au square
de la porte de la villette où un mur
qualifiée de mur de la honte a été
construit afin de les empêcher de passer
les portes de paris des lieux d'accueil
qui reste compliqué à définir et des
solutions proposées par le gouvernement
qui ne satisfont pas à la région
ile-de-france
valérie pécresse s'est déplacé le 26
septembre dernier pour dénoncer les
méthodes du gouvernement créer un mur ça
veut dire enfermés ça veut dire enfermés
enfermer les gens dans leur leur
situation sociale enfermer les gens dans
leur territoire et ça n'est pas possible
et donc on ne peut pas installer ces
toxicomanes entre paris et las
seine-saint-denis c'est juste pas
possible il faut réussir à créer une
structure candidate à l'élection
présidentielle valérie pécresse en a
profité pour pointer du doigt l'inaction
d'anne hidalgo sa potentiel rival pour
le prochain scrutin une situation qui
prend des tournures d'affrontement
politique à quelques mois du scrutin
présidentiel
ce jeudi une réunion a malgré tout
permis de trouver des solutions afin de
faire évoluer la situation en mettant de
côté les désaccords entre la mairie de
paris et la région ile de france le
ministre de l'intérieur a de son côté
estimé avoir pris ses responsabilités et
a laissé entendre que trouver des lieux
d'accueil pour les toxicomanes étaient
désormais le devoir de la ville de paris